he talked to former Capitol Police
Officer Tara Johnson about what happened
that day and what officer Johnson tried
to do as the events were unfolding take
a look at this once protesters moved
inside the building Johnson's first
concern was the safety of senators his
job was to protect them in Rising Panic
he called over the radio for direction
and assistance even now two years later
he is baffled by the response he got I
was requesting permission to evacuate
the Senate side
um the Senate chambers because I had a
clear line of sight to get them out the
Senate door and I didn't get permission
um the dispatcher called a couple times
to see if I can get permission no
response with Yogananda Pittman and his
other supervisors unresponsive Johnson
says he decided to begin the evacuation
of senators himself the person that I
thought was going to authorize the
evacuation didn't do it I wanted to get
those members of Congress out as quickly
as I could that's why I initiated
um you know those evacuations me being
disciplined it wasn't as important as
not getting the members of Congress and
their staff to safety footage we
reviewed seems to bolster Johnson's okay
so this is interesting you have a
capital police officer not getting a
response when he's saying hey uh Mob of
people and they're supposed to be evil
white supremacists and insurrectionists
and blah blah blah mob of people on
their way into the capitol could we
maybe get the Senators and the
congressman out of here he's getting no
response so he does it himself if if you
are all in on the idea that this was a
true insurrection that these were
violent people who were going to kill
members of Congress overthrow the
government and Usher in a wave of Maga
Terror saying then this is the hero in
the story isn't this guy the hero in the
story because he actually did get
senators and congressmen out he also
happens to be a young black guy which
again if you're playing the identity
politics game everyone why don't why
doesn't everyone know him his name why
doesn't everyone know the name tarek
Johnson here is a young police officer
who saved the Senators on January 6.
this everyone should know his name alas
we do not and you're not going to
believe this he got fired the video
shows Johnson conducting the evacuation
of senators from the chamber yet Tark
Johnson was not rewarded for what he did
he was punished a photo emerged of
Johnson wearing a Maga hat outside the
capitol that picture cost him his career
sometimes I look at it and like thank
you God for blessing me with this hat
and sometimes I'm like
wow I wish this hat never came in my
life a Biden voter Johnson says he
donned the Hat in an effort to rescue
fellow officers he believed were trapped
in the building I figured if I had the
Hat on it'll be easier for me to
navigate my way through the crowd it was
basically self-preservation and
de-escalation
um and I needed to get up those steps I
couldn't say what would have happened
walking through that crowd without it
but for the crime of wearing a trump hat
Johnson found himself suspended
ultimately he resigned from the force
and lost his pension he now works
part-time as a Furniture mover all right
so this is really wild so tarek Johnson
a Biden voter
puts the Hat on because he did have some
concerns about the people and he thought
all right I'm going to get in there as a
police officer let me put the Hat on
they'll think I'm a friendly and I can
continue to do my work and if people
need to be rescued or moved or whatever
it might be I can go ahead and do it
this guy is the hero of the story he
ultimately got suspended for that then
as Tucker said he resigns now he's
moving furniture and nobody nobody knows
his name for the set of people that love
to really Drive someone's name into your
brain relentlessly often when they don't
deserve it as Heroes that guy should be
considered a hero foreign
[Music]